op o pessoal e quem falou da crise junto
em imagens é mais um em um estrago de
que finalmente uma coisa fácil entender
muito muito muito um vídeo de todo o
amor de vocês comentam que tenha saudade
de mim sinto hoje o terceiro teste aqui
uns vamos fazer uma coisa continuada com
o terror porque já faz há muito tempo e
eu confesso que até já tem alguma
saudada ufpe o encontrei muito jogo na
internet mas não vou jogar hoje não os
vamos fazer apenas um contexto esteja
quase um jogo né mas peraí vou explicar
e perfuma foi revisto sua mãe gentil me
explicar o que fazer com um acordo muito
importante com você é já que muita gente
vê terror e com muita gente tem jogado
de cima o conteúdo antigo hoje eu dei um
toque se você já é muito consumido
organic com fáceis de filhos deixem
muito líquidos filho subscrevam
pertinentes filho como o máximo de
pessoas possa se conectar a um casal
então se tiver muito feedback nesse
período vou tentar os fluxos inserir
mais terror aqui no canal que vocês
gostam e eu acho que também vou estar
tudo isso vive mas só não só assim eu
imaginei ter um evento andré neves
nilson rodrigues que já nem vale a pena
fazer é como apagar esta casa com um
tímido não lá então é só por terem como
as pessoas mas o principal mesmo você
interagir e deixarem muito rica muito
comentário faça o máximo possível porque
não sei se vocês sabem mas eu deixei
isto continua assim de flores jogos de
ditadores porque a própria plataforma
youtube já não é assim tão amigável
deste tipo de conteúdo do canal do
youtube quer sobreviver na plataforma
tem cada vez de adaptar se ao culto quer
juntamente com cuja inscritos querem
juntamente com que a pessoa gosta e eu
tento sempre fazer mas que os vistos
vocês mas condutor e uendel gosto de
touros lógico temos vocês publicarem ao
máximo e vou continuar a fazer o café é
um corpo mas como estava a dizer hoje
não se conhece nenhum jogo porque eu vi
muito bem interessante mas não quer
fazer chá eu quero cortar o que não
posso dizer é que eu quero que vocês
gostam e para além disso eu quero saber
se o endereço jogar porque precisamos
passar um tempinho efe pessoal o que vão
fazer os gols da gente fazer um teste de
tudo lá é um bilhete timbu caiu num
vídeo é da última edição em not the
screen orquestra vai receber intelcenter
ímpar
parece que o cv 2016 está um texto muito
duro em vida
tem muito minuto o que vai acontecer
daqui pessoal silva de estar com
espírito eu vou voltar a fazer jogos de
terror colocar eu vou tentar e se
jogarem ao cinema história eu acho que
ela venha experimentar né méxico mantém
o que vocês acham que só o assunto
voltar mas no longo prazo
[Música]
bora lá pessoal fones no ouvido fácil
vocês também ok deixando muito mal olha
tudo isso há de tudo
a lei é o medo eo terror é o seu doente
da cabeça e um guia proibição ser 321
the ultimate fighting escrever em
português para 31 pai atacante willian é
um o aviso vencedor e isso tem apenas
feito com a taxa é colar visualizador
este teste é feito apenas para pessoas
bravas suas curiosas eles basicamente
aqueles que têm que seguir as regras
regra número 1 tem cuidado porque este
texto contém um jeans kers ou seja tem
insistido que fazem parte da cadeia de
classe na regra mesmo show de rock por
favor tenha certeza que apagar as luzes
e colocam o show de edson só quem já
tenha que o sporting está bem alto mas
infelizmente não consegui apagar as
luzes por tem uma janela e tem muito sol
então eu acho que não conseguiria pagar
só aí é uma coisa pessoal já me
esquecendo é só pra dizer que três
gostavam forum sintra já esteve três
então apareceu uma pessoa vão de xira
que o público quer muita gente a sério
vamos conversar eu vou tirar foto e
gostar quando todos vocês por tanta
pressão lá mesmo é muito importante
fazer lá no instagram porque vou dizer
os pormenores relativamente a horários
de conta que eu gostar precisamente
então passei lá é explicada não só para
mim mas quero e mats imagem de nossa
senhora da luz está muito alto
olha o stream uma menina olha só a ilha
tem uma fratura na boca mesmo
o vírus está já conheço estudo
eu tô falando em não conseguir ouvir a
minha voz político está muito alta em
relação ao negócio então se eu disser
porcaria porque não conseguiu a virada
porém este aqui é o de reiki nível 2
pronto já possui um nível muito fácil
muito fácil onde passou para chegar ao
título ainda é muito fácil botar tudo
preto queijo opa vai com o passado que
bicho não fez nada tudo preto
aí 33 1/3 de imitá lo aqui no chão mas
só vocês não conseguirão ver melhor as
nossas escolas são prata gel em parte
tudo só alguém militar verdade parece
firme para não fazer isso
o cache história está assim tanto faz
confusão para consultar se há na minha
volta mas o papa se outra imagem nível 3
querem guedes
agora ele vive agora já mexe o ou o país
e que já sabia quais é muita coisa que
eu já vi lembrando a bola e saiu da
piscina com o prédio foi construído há
florestas tudo torto
tá com os partidos se encontrarem e pá
não brinquem com o méxico não merece é a
minha cabeça passa muito rápido muito
isso é muita coisa a respeito basta que
ela ia sair assustou
estou em garanhuns
olha só agora está tranqüilo
[Música]
entre eu tinha uma vida nova em relação
a essa mara muito fácil é o palhaço
então fala japonês
estamos tem um monte de bicho é o mais
complicado
não vás na porta não vacina for velho é
fechado ontem por dentro da lei mas
morreu assim não ela nem se o porta-voz
claro que o bicho não era uma fêmea com
carta branca
eu estou aqui com muito medo do que aí
floresta
otto uma pessoa em cima de uma criança
infectada nível quatro sequer e viu sua
vida
não achei que estava nadando até agora
que os vídeos está complicado agora tem
um monte na escada ser mal nem mas nosso
império agora para o cemitério do mpe
não estou a ver o que está acontecendo
aqui
um homem vestido com papel higiênico uma
pessoa em um canto só faltava o livro
mas isto não é uma pessoa é uma sombra
era uma sombra confunde tudo não sou
lento
ok estamos numa sala mas que fantasmas
estudam o que as pessoas fazem esta
edição e pensam que há pessoas que vão
achar que aquilo é mesmo lado
acho que o time já tem uma chinesa
já o tanque está no rio
olha a janela de freio e pessoal não
posso dizer vem porque eu deixei de
fazer duro não dar o youtube só que
fernando feliz e não posso em três
motéis
[Risadas]
eu ouvi um grito muito alta que não
houve corrupção é como a vida né
outra sombra não vai decretar através do
meo
nilsinho foi um teste e já é sócia o
texto
eu já vi ela vai se mexer e não vai
atingir a imagem refletida no espelho e
me espelho nas minhas irmãs silva
escreveu eu sou meu sonho é muito alto
é este que também já me é aquela que vai
encher a opa hostil sozinho ia descer
que lutava como é que eu já vi este não
lembrava até porque mil do exercício
muita pressão todos o ar mas esquece que
foi pessoal é não conseguir passar a
vocês quem tem isso vocês conseguiram
passar ou não já sabem investir muito
mais aqui neste vídeo cometem por fim
com os vossos inimigos se realmente
quiser a abertura aqui no canal passam
tudo isso que eu escolhi ok é muito
importante perceber se vocês querem vão
estar realmente visto também cuido já
não ajuda muito de chuvas neto e pelo
celular 21% meu público é que recebe a
notificação por seu quarto rua ingaí
plataforma já nem gosto e ainda vou ter
muito menos é então é muito importante
que mesmo a vossa ajuda sério e já sabem
de 3 gostar não foram sempre comprei
também um livro em quetta na descrição
eo costume de estudar uma novidade em
relação ao bloqueio de quente quando
integrava um formulário tudo ok só para
fazer se no estado fiquem bem até a
próxima